la jaula le gusta mucho estudiar pero ha
tenido que ponerse a trabajar las
escuelas están cerradas desde hace más
de un año por la pandemia es refugiada
con pocos recursos y tiene que compartir
un teléfono móvil con toda la familia
cosas antes de adaptar en la ciudad
como soy la mayor mi madre me encontró
un trabajo y así puedo ayudar a mi
familia la norma sí
la crisis económica ha empujado a niños
como jaula a trabajar ya cambiar los
lápices y cuadernos por un taller de
lavado de coches recogida de basura o la
venta de frutas y verduras me gustaría
seguir estudiando en la escuela e ir a
la universidad pero los refugiados
tenemos pocas oportunidades para
continuar con los estudios y eso me pone
muy triste
ayala el incremento del número de niños
que trabajan dentro de las comunidades
más vulnerables ha hecho saltar las
alarmas de las organizaciones
humanitarias frente al silencio de las
autoridades libanesas la situación en el
líbano sigue empeorando cada vez más
niños no tienen acceso a la educación y
como consecuencia aumenta alarmantemente
el trabajo infantil el matrimonio
infantil y la violencia doméstica no
solo los refugiados han visto
interrumpida su educación con más del 55
por ciento de la población libanesa bajo
el umbral de la pobreza muchos padres se
enfrentan a dificultades para que sus
hijos puedan seguir estudiando
y mi hijo ha ido solo dos meses al
colegio en dos años por la mañana tengo
que ir a trabajar y se queda con mi
madre y no estudia cuando regreso del
trabajo me pongo a hacer deberes con él
yo le enseñado a escribir y a leer
el líbano se enfrenta a la peor crisis
económica décadas
y a una catástrofe educativa estamos
hablando de 1,2 millones de niños que no
han regresado a la escuela desde que
comenzó la pandemia los economistas
advierten de una generación perdida una
situación que no se repite desde la
guerra civil libanesa